thank you very much for great briefing  for support we never forget your help  and we see who real friends of Ukraine  it's very important in this difficult  critical period of time is we see who  are real friends of Ukraine but we never  forget it thank you for every families  who take Ukrainian refugees who help  your brain without your help is almost  to be impossible to survive  and I hope the new prime minister do it  exactly the same way because everyone  have to understand right now we  understand not just Ukraine not just our  families we different defend right now  the waters the international waters and  the main Wallace human rights press the  freedom Democratic Waters and we're  fighting for that